good morning councillors officers
members of the public and welcome to
this extraordinary meeting of cambridge
district council's full council
so should the fire alarm sound please
leave the room
by the nearest exit and meet by the
stand at the far end of the car park
if you wish to speak please raise your
hand and a boom microphone will be
brought over to you please speak make
sure you speak into the microphone
otherwise you won't be heard on the live
stream there is no need for members to
stand up when they are speaking you're
free to to remain seated
please keep your points short and i ask
members not to repeat points that have
already been raised voting will be by a
show of hands
should the meeting be adjourned any
filming must cease unless the expressed
permission from those being filled has
been obtained
if there is an adjournment i would ask
that members public and officers please
re leave the room until the meeting
reconvenes
and finally i just like to remind
members
that a member who has spoken on a motion
may not speak again whilst it is the
subject of debate except to speak once
on an amendment moved by another member
or to move a further amendment if the
motion has been amended since they last
spoke so we will be trying to keep
fairly strictly to one contribution per
member in during the debate
so moving on then uh do we have any
apologies for absence
yes we have councillors cook dewhurst
eden
goodman bradbury piet wrigley
orm
[Music]
yeah sorry i couldn't see it in the
light and councilor sylvia russell
thank you
um item two on the agenda do we have any
declarations of interest
uh council of peterington
thank you thank you chairman yes i'm a
member of the planning committee so i
feel that i might need to abstain when
it comes to the vote on this this item
thank you mrs okay thank you councillor
i saw another hand cancer jaws
oh yes uh as i think people know i'm a
member of the
conceptual cbs community benefit society
for the alexandra theater
i've asked for dispensation to speak and
vote on this matter i've been granted
dispensation to speak on the matter uh
and
the advice i have is that uh that that
ruling is is not in line with the
localism act uh therefore as a point of
order i'd like to ask if the same
rules have been applied to other uh
unpaid directorships of
of societies and whether uh councillors
councillors wrigley and hook
with the interests of
the new nub at cic will also
being asked not to vote on this matter
thank you
it's appropriate for me to comment now i
did um ask after the last meeting
because
um
in certain sympathy with councillor
doors i suppose i i wanted to check that
things were carried out correctly
and what i was told was that my
directorship at newton now that cic
is more
a general organization it doesn't have
any specific
purposes or aims related to
council projects in any detail
i can't recount the aims and purposes
right now but they're very general about
the general welfare of newtonia but as a
town and a community and they have no
direct bearing on any pacific council
projects whereas obviously um
council adores directorship
is related to a particular project which
has a bearing on a council current
council project and and that is the
difference i'm told thank you
councillor dawes
the point of order there is the new
number crc runs the venue in the uh in
the town of newton but that is actually
that is commercial that rents out space
that is uh operates uh screening
facilities that is could be perceived as
being in direct competition with it with
other facilities in the town uh
therefore i'd like to know who offered
that advice because i don't think that
is consistent advice and falls into the
uh what i suggested previously is that
councillors
of political uh
persuasions are being treated
differently and and given advantage by
by uh the senior officers in in this
council
i'm counselled sorry but just checking
in the procedural rules a member may
raise a point of order at any time but a
point of order may only relate to an
alleged breach of the rules of procedure
or the law
so you are in breach of the localism act
by not allowing me to vote on the matter
may i ask the monitoring officer to
respond to that please
chair there's no breach despite what the
council might allege or assert
there are no there are no breaches he
has
as was discussed at the last full
council and has been explained to him on
the number of occasions in writing by me
he has
a
disclosable peculiar interest in respect
of this matter that's on the agenda
before council that is why he has to
declare it that is why he had to leave
the room on the last occasion he
submitted a request yesterday albeit
five o'clock on friday evening sorry
which i looked at yesterday
there were no supporting grounds in them
put forward in support of the request i
considered this application for
dispensation i spoke to the chair of
standards
we agreed that on balance
he should be given the dispensation to
speak today in because of his background
and involvement in the
in the um sector that we're discussing
and it as and as such it would be
informative potentially to the to
members and we considered it appropriate
to grant him dispensation to speak but
not to vote the reason for not voting is
because his interest directly
is directly linked to the matter before
council
he
his organization i understand has
submitted a planning application
i'm not quite sure how close or how much
more of a conflict a member could have
which is why we decided he should not be
allowed to speak
there are no breaches of the code there
are no breaches of the law it is as it
is in respect of council hook council
wrigley as they've been mentioned
their interests
the rules would apply to them in the
same way as the as this if their
organization to which they are directors
or
any other
or whether they hold any other
office in respect of that organization
if something came forward to council
that directly affected that organization
the same rules would apply to them
corruption
the the localism act does not
define disposable disclosable pecuniary
interest as being a non-paid executive
executive a non-paid director of a
charitable organization that is the law
you are misinterpreting the law that is
mal administration
chair clearly council of doors is
insistent on expressing his own opinion
i've written to him i've explained why
there are no conflicts why the rules
aren't being applied differently
regardless of political persuasion to
suggest otherwise is a little bit of an
insult and a bit rich
but nevertheless the localism act sets
out the default position which has to be
included within the code of conduct i've
explained and i've pointed counselor
doors to the sections which allow the
council to add to that which it has
chosen to do by adding non-paid
directors there are no conflicts there
are no breaches
counselor
i think people thought i wasn't coming
but i am here um just as a matter of
clarity really we've had one counselor
already uh declaring interest because he
is on the planning committee
now if that is correct then surely all
the other seven all the other 16 members
of the planning committee who are here
today should also declare the same
interest and also not be allowed to vote
thank you
it's a matter of counsel
i suggest that that's a matter for
councillors and their own conscience
it is the same for cancer doors
this whole thing is fixed
cancerity regarding um counselor jackie
hook's
statement she made a short while ago
could she share with us who gave her
this advice regarding her position
and also
notwithstanding that advice whether she
might want to reflect whether she will
indeed vote on this matter perhaps
bearing in mind one word integrity
i i'm not sure the council of hook has
that kind of interest in this and it's
it's not relevant
she stated she had received advice
actually
stated
advice on her position i think it's fair
to ask who advised her she's an officer
of cambridge district council or is it
someone outside this organization that
if so who identity counselor hook is is
under any obligation to reveal from whom
she obtained advice
okay
uh with respect can counselor hook make
that decision herself
counselor hook
um yeah i'm not prepared to say you gave
that advice but i wanted to make a
comment on the surprise on the planning
committee issue obviously there are a
number of us here that are on planning
committee
i
i don't believe there is any reason just
because you're on planning committee
that you can't vote to contribute some
more money or not to a council project
the consideration of the planning
components of that project are an
entirely different thing and i've
separated them in my mind
and so i have concerns on both but i've
separated them out and i feel planning
committee members can make a separate
decision about whether they would want
to fund or not the cinema project before
us
thank you councillor i think um it's
time to move oh
councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um in the matter of
dispensations it is worth noting that
the dispensation can be granted in the
interests of residents in the authority
area
um bearing in mind that the uh
petition that was signed regarding the
alexander theatre represented several
thousand people
not including those who sign from
outside the area
i would suspect that at the very least
council doors should be given the
opportunity to debate the matter fully
on the basis that it is in the interest
of residents of this authority area it's
this is a significant amount of spend in
this authority area
thank you
um i as i understand it from the head of
legal services and our monitoring
officer uh that is why council of laws
has been given this dispensation to
participate in the debate
um but unfor according to the head of
legal services uh there is no
dispensation for council of doors to
vote
right moving on then we move to item
three the main item on our agenda today
which is the recommendation uh for a
capital budget increase to miss it on
the future high street fund to mitigate
cost inflation related to the newton
cinema construction and fit out and i
ask councillor jeffries the executive
member for economy and jobs to move the
recommendation
thank you chair
the report before members today seeks an
additional capital budget of up to six
hundred thousand pounds in relation to
the construction and fit out costs for
the new full screen cinema in youth nava
the cinema is fundamental part of the
plans for transformational change to
newton abbott town centre
as you're aware we have secured 5.2
million
pounds of government grant funding
towards the overall project cost of 7.5
million to enable this to happen
this is a significant investment that
would never happen without the future
high street fund
the council is also securing a 7.5
million pound asset for a 2.3 million
pound investment
while there has been significant
volatility in several areas that have
contributed to the rising costs and
uncertainty the proposal before you
offers a solution that delivers on the
council's ambitions secures a
long-standing tenant and still provides
a return on investment above one percent
we have also received the following
message from scott cinemas ahead of
today's discussion
scott cinemas have a long-standing
interest in newton abbott having
operated the alexandra for over 25 years
and believe there is a real potential in
the town to have a thriving modern used
cinema as part of the wider development
and investment in market walk and the
pannier market
whilst
all out of home venues face great
challenges at present cinema going
remains a much-loved activity as
demonstrated in national cinema day last
saturday with over 1.4 million people
attending a uk cinema on just one day
as a company we are fully committed to
operating in newton abbot and excited
about the opportunity to deliver a new
full screen state-of-the-art venue for
the town
chairman i now move to accept the
recommendations as set out
[Music]
yes thank you chairman
um chairman i think the amendment uh
deals with process within council it's
important that the amendment is moved at
the beginning
so i the amendment is that the council
resolves two and there are three parts
commission its external auditors grant
thornton or another appropriately
skilled and qualified external audit
provider to review and report on the
governance of the future high street
fund in relation to the commissioning
construction costs and contracting for
the proposed news cinema and the
information provided to council to make
an informed decisions
the report to be commissioned as a
matter of urgency and presented to the
audit scrutiny committee for
consideration and any further
recommendations
two that with effect from october 2022
officers present a comprehensive written
report for each executive meeting
whether it's held or not on delivery of
the future high street fund in its
various projects the report will set out
key objectives and timelines
progress towards them identify when
decisions will need identify when
decisions will need to be made by the
council or the executive and all other
necessary relevant information about the
future high street fund to keep
councillors fully informed and if
necessary the report may be part two or
an exempt item and finally three
chairman
pending receipt of the report
commissioned in one above
council adjourns to a date to be
confirmed when it will consider the
officer recommendation for an additional
capital budget of up to six hundred
thousand pounds in relation to the
cinema construction and fit out costs
chairman i have a copy of that because i
appreciate committee clark will probably
need that thank you very much
uh thank you councilman before before we
move to to consider and debate that
amendment
councillor patch
thank you chad i was just going to
request that all votes on this match
that is
proposal is carried thank you councillor
pat
uh
seeking advice from the monitoring
officer on this if it's a recorded vote
in part two
which would i presume remain a
confidential minute i just like
clarification to actually people might
wish to disclose that whereas it's
confidential if it's part two so i'd
welcome some advice on that please
mr woodhead chair thank you members um
the
vote uh
will be in part one
so um
the the debate in part two for obvious
reasons
um and then we'll come back out of part
two back into part one in order for the
vote to be taken
which is similar to the reasons why the
uh
recommendations et cetera are put
forward in part one
yes uh thank you council haynes i was
going to propose that we moved to part
two for the
so to enable a full and frank discussion
but do we go back to part one for for
the vote to be public
councillors will have heard the proposed
amendment uh from councillor connect
which was in three parts commissioning a
report
it
has been seconded by seconded by
councillor keeling thank you
um
the first part was to commission a
report from the external auditors uh in
relation to commissioning construction
costs and contracting for the proposed
new cinema
um
part two
a comprehensive written report for each
executive meeting whether or not on the
future high street fund and the third
part of the
amendment uh pending receipt of the
report from the
external auditors proposed the council
now adjourns to a date to be confirmed
when it can consider the recommendation
for an additional capital budget of up
to 600 000 pounds so council economy is
proposing this meeting is in fact
adjourned until that report comes from
the auditors and
therefore a full and frank debate and
discussion with sufficient information
is is possible councillor connect
i reserve my opportunity to speak to the
motion and amendment later on
i'm quite happy for members to go into
part two and have a debate i simply
wanted to set out an amendment uh
whereby
we await further information as in
adjourn the meeting uh rather than vote
on the 600 000 today but i uh respect
that members that will have come today
with wishing to debate the item and i
think they absolutely should uh but i
don't think we should necessarily take
the vote on the matter today that's uh
the view enhanced the amendment
thank you council o'connor
managing director yeah
thank you chairman um appreciate that um
the leaders brought forward
an amendment um
we haven't seen the amendment so
therefore we haven't had a chance to
look at the impact of that i don't know
i've just given a copy to
um the strategic lead for the project
neil blaney to have a look at um would
it be appropriate for an officer to give
a comment on that because
initially i have concerns about the
delivery of the project past this given
that
whether we can actually meet the time
scale given that this would delay the
project for a number of months
uh potentially
getting grant funding to do that so
we need to give advice i mean i don't
know neil hasn't had a chance to look at
it or or tom who's working on the
project and has been speaking to the
future high streets
uh civil servants about funding and the
movement of that date that would give us
an absolute need to spend the money by
2024
a councillor relevant
thank you and i appreciate the amendment
that's been put forward my concern is
we have
a professional team of officers who have
worked effectively and managed to
finances this council for many years
151 officer is extremely experienced
has worked on similar projects over many
years
and i can't understand why this
amendment has suddenly been brought
forward now when presumably the leader
has been able to work with officers to
put these ideas together and why is it
now that we should suddenly challenge
the decision of an officer and a
recommendation the officer saying that
it should go out to an external
external body to assess whether the
officer's recommendation is valid or not
i find that uh difficult to understand
thank you
counselling to patrick
thank you
i'm really sorry to have to say this but
for me this seems an absolute mess i've
got no clue what i'm supposed to be
voting for today
and the fact that something's been
brought forward without officers
knowledge
is
is unacceptable and i just don't see how
i can vote on any of all this today
because i just don't know it's like
being in a tumble driver you don't know
whether you're coming or going it's one
thing one minute it's another last last
meeting we were told it was all going to
be withdrawn
then we suddenly get
noticed to come to an extraordinary
meeting to vote for another six
hundred thousand pounds for it for
something that's been withdrawn but
obviously must be coming back again then
we get here and we're told that there's
an amendment to it that the officers
know nothing about it that's just
disgusting as far as i'm concerned
cancel malone
there is an lgo guideline that a vote
must be carried out within a timely
distance of the debate that preceded it
that there's no value at all in debating
something
today all the key points of which will
have been forgotten by the time these
figures come available i mean what is
the point of that there's no point at
all
i'm all for it on another matter i'm all
for it because uh
cineworld is going into administration
by the time this happens a view cinemas
will be there scot cinemas still haven't
as far as i know have signed a contract
all that's going to happen is that this
idea will look even more ridiculous in a
couple of months time
it comes to healing
thank you very much mr chairman
i support the leaders amendments
and
an independent external audit and
oversight by the
executive will give the public the
confidence that the six hundred thousand
is spent well if we agree that thank you
thank you constitution councillor swain
thank you chair
i note the comments about this being
sudden
and i agree with that
but the comment about the vote having to
be close to the debate is not relevant
because going to debate the amendment at
this point and we will vote on that
immediately um
it is sudden but there's quite a lot of
things happening very suddenly and i was
surprised reading this report to learn
that scots hadn't been signed up to the
whole deal
and still aren't for example um the
extra 600 pound requirement
has appeared very suddenly
so i don't think it's fair to criticize
the amendment for being sudden
um it's responding to the situation that
we find ourselves in
not so long ago i was in this room
being
asked by some people to consider an
alternative plan for the alex and i was
advised by experts that there was a 500
000 pound hole in the budget for that
i took that very seriously and i voted
against the proposal which potentially
had significant costs associated with
with it um but now we seem to be facing
perfectly valid reasons but we seem to
be facing an equally large hole
in this budget
which we may or may not be able to
afford but we have to be responsible
with public money
and we must be very careful for that
reason i wholeheartedly support uh the
amendment
to get some proper scrutiny on this
about the six hundred thousand where
it's going to come from as well
um
i
am concerned about borrowing those
comment um
there's a comment that i've heard made
that that scots uh are
well placed in the current climate
because they don't borrow they grow
their business organically and reinvest
borrowing is a high risk strategy
especially at the current times and we
need to be very careful about the money
so i absolutely support the amendment
thank you very much
thank you councillor swain council patch
thank you chair um
i think it's probably about going on a
year since we were first towed how tight
the time scale was with this how we
could brook no no no reconsiderations
no changes no no tweaks of direction
particularly regarding the um the fate
of the alexandra theater and yet now
when we're at what sort of five to
midnight um relatively speaking on hope
project
and putting into threat these millions
of pounds of money that might come into
the um
the district we're being told just hang
on we'll just
we won't make a decision now we'll kick
it into long grass again
what is this is this is this um a simple
failure of leadership of vision is it
incompetence or is it a cynical attempt
to get to the stage where this council
is presented with a fate to complete
we're out of time this is what we're
going to have to do
i i think we have to take a decision
today i will be voting against this
amendment um
i i i really i i well i could speculate
as to what where how this has come about
today but i'd probably best not do that
i i think this council needs to get a
grip make a decision on this if we're
not to spend this money we need to give
officers the time
to pull something out of the wreckage of
what's been happening over the last 12
months certainly and come up with a
viable plan for the future high streets
fund that will enhance this town and
this district
council connor do you wish to respond
chairman thank you very much i have no
difficulty with the officer's advice and
recommendation of the council obviously
it's prepared and it's for members
to make their decision
however having listened to members over
an extended period of time a number of
occasions have been expressed about the
concern about the
information available to counselors to
make decisions about whether there's
some external verification of it so that
members make the most the best and most
informed decision
we've not had the opportunity to ask
grant thornton or another external audit
provider to have a look at it i don't
believe it will necessarily take an
overly long time i think it could be
done very quickly uh within weeks i
would have thought and the council could
then reconvene with that knowledge i
also think that during the course of the
debate whether it's in part one or part
two today issues may arise which might
cause counselors to think we would
actually like some external validation
for that so that they do make an
informed decision it's not just the up
to six hundred thousand being asked for
today but we're all aware that
construction cost inflation is rising
and there may be future costs of
delivering this project for the council
and it is well that the council is aware
of that or the potential of it now
rather than having to come back in some
later point because it's asked for more
money because of construction inflation
the amendment today was to provide
three things
the first is the external overview to
support the officer's recommendation
the second was to provide a monthly
written report on progress of future
issue fund something that we've not had
so i'm interested that those councillors
have been calling for more information
now so they don't want it and then
thirdly to adjourn the meeting to enable
that information to be provided from the
external author and then reconvene and
discuss and decide with the full
information or the endorsement of the
officer information available to them if
members don't wish to support the
amendment that's fine that's their right
and prerogative
but they have the opportunity to do now
the one thing they've said they've
always wanted chairman thank you
thank you cancer councillor dawes i
think your hand was next
hi thanks and uh
i uh funnily enough actually welcome
anything that puts the brakes on uh on
on this spend because i don't think the
council uh is in a position to make a a
a a sensible and uh well judged view
because the current situation is is
indeed so fluid uh there's been talk
about uh the the status of scot cinemas
uh as a trading entity i don't think the
uh financial director of scott cinemas
can even say with any certainty what the
status of their organization is every
single venue operator of any scale in
the country
is lobbying the government to have their
energy bills capped they've gone up by
some of them by 600 per cent
so uh what we've seen with cineworld who
clearly saw the writing on the wall and
have taken the best advice gone into
administration we will be seeing an
awful lot of that in in the next six to
twelve months whatever happens even if
the energy
price is capped as it is now which is
already uh eye-wateringly high increases
so the the there there is there is no
certainty at all the the frustration
that i i would share
uh the the councillor patrick put
forward is that uh uh
it's just the surprise of this because
uh of of course we we've we've come back
from uh uh an august break and we've had
the this meeting put forward uh and then
at the very last minute at
another screeching u-turn
um
surely the the writing was on the wall
when this meeting was was was uh was
actually thought of maybe a couple of
weeks ago
um
so
it's very frustrating to have spent most
of my time yesterday
uh
taking legal advice on on the localism
act then debating that here at this
morning and then to be told actually
there is no debate on spending the the
six hundred thousand pounds because
we've decided we want to get somebody
else to look at it i mean we could have
told you that months and months ago
thank you
councillor malone
thank you if i could just uh throw
another pair of pants into councillor
pederix washing machine um
i would actually support this amendment
with an amendment to this amendment
because by all means talk to the
council's bean counters about the money
but please get some consultation on the
state of cinema
today
because vu has issued a profits warning
sydney world's going into administration
there is no contract with the small firm
of scots
and their whole business plan seems to
be to say i know we're only quarter
filling houses now but if we had four
screens we'd fill the whole thing that
is not a business plan
nobody has survived on that kind of
business plan you are looking at a huge
tupperware box of a building with
nothing going on in it and you are going
to look extremely stupid so please for
your own sake get some consultation on
where cinema is and where you know the
nighttime economy is
and how much sense this really makes
please just do that
is that a formal amendment to the
amendment council malone seconded by
councillor patch
councillor patch
if i may chair
i'd like to table an amendment to the
amendment to the amendment um
to advise me as to the logistics of this
whether it's indeed possible perhaps
you'd hear my proposal first um i would
like to propose a vote of no confidence
in the leader and executive of this
council for having brought us to this
situation now
i don't know
councillor patch i don't think that's an
amendment
uh it is it is not accepted as an
amendment
it's a completely new motion
uh
sorry
cancer morgan you had your hand up
[Music]
thank you um
i find myself um
in part agreement with both councillor
doors and um
councillor pederick but i also support
this amendment by councillor connect
because it does effectively put a pause
on us spending more of more taxpayers
money a rather large amount of taxpayers
money six hundred thousand pounds
and
you know when the future high street
fund was envisaged four five years ago
i'm guessing they didn't envisage a
future like this none of us did
um
and you know it's it's scary for a lot
of us and and and i would quite gain a
lot of
reassurance from an external
partner an external um
group with a dispassionate view on this
to give us their opinion before we go
ahead any further i think it's a really
pragmatic thing to do
and
you know it it will give my committee as
um audit scrutiny uh a fair bit of work
to do but i i would relish that before
we actually put our hands in our pockets
and and spend any more on this
um and i would suggest maybe not grant
thornton but the southwest audit
partnership
who
will have some familiarization with the
southwest and the economy of the
southwest
but yes i report support this amendment
very much so because i think we need to
put a pause on this take a step back
take someone's dispassionate view on
what is a very passionate
topic for a lot of people
thank you councilman
um in a moment i'm going to ask officer
blaney to comment on the original
amendment
put forward by
councillor con it but there is a second
amendment and i'm going to ask council
malone
could you clarify precisely what your
amendment to the amendment is please
because we will need to vote on that
uh to secure some consultation in in
partnership with the consulting with the
um with the accountants to secure some
consultation on the state of cinema
in the present day and the nighttime
economy of south devon
our members clear as to what that
amendment is
yes
thank you and and thus to
to to make a a clear review on the
viability of opening a brand new full
screen cinema
thank you councilman
did you have a comment cancel
cancel connect
i think actually the managing director
and our officers have been in touch with
montague evans independently advising
the council on the cinema matter perhaps
when we move into part two they may be
able to explain uh the work that's been
undertaken in that and that may result
in counseling alone being satisfied or
you know he may wish to pursue uh his
further amendment uh but but i do know
officers have been seeking that external
advice and guidance but i think that is
a matter of part two
when we eventually get their channel
thank you
why can't the public know about the
viability of this project
uh cancer patch
[Music]
sorry go out
the potential viability of this project
why must this be hidden in part two
i don't think that's the
managing director
well i wasn't commenting on that part
yet but um in terms of if i could come
back to the audit element um
uh as council morgan said but audit
scrutiny on the 30th i believe agreed
the audit plan the internal elements of
that included
um
and we can change that quite happy to
change that but it included the review
of the delivery of major projects so
that's in line with what you're asking
but we can focus that quite quickly on
their
review of the risk management processes
of the council and the governance
as well so there was a con
contained within the audit scrutiny in
the audit plan for the next 12 months so
that that should be
in line with what you're asking for in
terms of councilman morgan and the
committee and whether you want to get
that to go out um that will be something
we will have to kind of come back to you
and just talk to you about how that
works
so i don't think that's inconsistent
with what members are asking
now in terms of
we would have to just take advice on
that because obviously there's some
issues potentially around the
commercial sensitivity of some of the
information
but i'd have to take a view
uh thank you mrs
cancer mcgregor
thank you chair um
you know i think from my perspective i
think council economy has to be
commended on this sudden desire for
transparency um
late in the day admittedly in this this
respect i have certain concerns some of
the mirror comments that have already
been made where are we finding the money
from
as a former member of the exec i had
concerns that we were trying to find 1.2
million pounds worth of savings one year
and then 2.4 million pounds worth of
savings the following year and yet we've
had to find additional funding for ford
house and now we're being asked for
additional funding for the cinema
project
so from my perspective you know trying
to establish where that money is coming
from
in detail
for councillors to make that decision
and i know council bulletin shaking his
head but we were trying to find savings
we are being asked for extra money
there's this potential risk here for the
council that we end up with
a cinema building which is unoccupied
for a great deal of time so while it
might be a 7.5 million pound asset for
2.5 million pounds if it's sitting empty
doing nothing it's not attracting
visitors it's not regenerating the high
street it's just being a very large
building in the middle of newton abbott
and that's fair i mean you know i'm i'm
not looking at it from the terms of
whether it's right or wrong but i'm
looking at the risks here as opposed to
the the the element but we should have
had reports we had a we had a meeting in
may
and the leader made an announcement that
the review would happen
over the next few months and we haven't
had that review
uh the managing director said that there
wasn't there wasn't time but now we're
being asked for a further six hundred
thousand pounds towards this project
there could be other existences that
involve more money in future so we're
talking about up to six hundred thousand
pound now but there could be increased
costs as councilor connor has already
pointed out
now my big problem with this is it's
there's a risk that this
freewheels and spirals out of control
and that we end up with a much heavier
investment in this process
when councilor conor made that
announcement in may i'm assuming that
he'd already spoken to officers about
the potential risk
has any attempt to be made to review the
actual design of the cinema
and whether or not that could be
cheapened so make it a three screen
cinema or a two screen cinema which is
either doubling or trebling what we have
currently at the alexandra and bearing
in mind
the attendance figures for that single
screen are not all that great we know
that we've got the we've got the the
evidence of that so
from from the perspective of of the way
that the contract is being delivered
are we looking at in enough options and
have we reviewed it well enough
before coming and asking for this 600
000 pounds because there are you know
you know i'm not saying that we
shouldn't regenerate because
now but needs the money it needs that
investment it needs that regeneration
but is this the right step and if we're
going to delay it
and delay and delay until it becomes a a
point of we must make a decision right
away and we can't really even debate it
at that point then we might as well
spend the next four weeks looking at
uh intensive
review of what we actually want to
deliver i think okay thank you
councilman mcgregor i think so what
you've been talking about now is
actually part of the debate of the
recommendations before us
and we are at the moment considering two
amendments um
can i ask sarah did you
amendment to the amendment were you
including the first of all the three
amendments that council
had put forward plus your one
regarding the consultation for the
viability yes thank you
um i'd like to ask officer neil blaney
to comment please uh if if that's
appropriate thank you
[Music]
yeah thank you chair um
i guess my comments on the amendment is
that we are just seeking um obviously
it's just come to us so we've not had
time to really reflect too much on it
but i've noticed a couple of the
comments about time scale and that's the
one that jumps out to me straight away
in that
we are up against it i mean the the time
scale for delivery of the project was
set out in april last year when members
signed off the project as a whole
within that document within those
reports
where the stages and steps required to
deliver all of the future high street
fund projects
and draw down the government funding by
march 2024
so there's been a series of activities
and actions all along
that we've been implementing and the
different stages
authorization is required for business
cases or for planner permission for
everything else
and
you know we are
at or past the critical point at which
there's no more slack in in our timeline
really
to do all the work needed to develop
plans
um for planning applications
um
and to to make sure that the
construction program has set out in the
timeline can be met
um
some of this work needs to start now
we've had to pause quite a few elements
of the work um in preparation for where
the cinema is going to go there's
negotiations with tenants
there's utilities we need to divert
and that's all been put on hold
because there's obviously a number of
issues that have arisen um and the
notice of motion that was brought up in
in july this year
so
um an additional month two months
means that
it's highly unlikely
we'll be able to meet the time scale
that we've had approval for
and then that puts the funding at risk
so the conversations we've had with the
future high street fund team
about our time scales is the deadline is
the deadline
and the expectation is we'll work
towards delivering that um and you know
we are still working on
the impacts from the notice of motion
and we've got a report to executive next
week regarding that so
in in considering this discussion today
for the members
clearly you'll decide what you feel is
the most appropriate course of action
but any additional delays to this
project
make it harder and harder for us to meet
the time scales as set out
which means that the government funding
element of the project um you know we do
not have certainty that the future high
street fund team when they come to
review
this year's spend which will be in
december this year and then they
allocate next year's spend if they've
got any concerns about the ability to
deliver they may withhold or withdraw
the funding so that's something we've
got to consider of of how we manage that
and clearly will if the decision today
is to accept the amendment we'll need to
go away and look at that
my initial view though is that it puts
us
further and further behind the time
scale
thank you officer blaine
councillor hook
thank you joe
um i just want to make a few comments i
suppose on the original amendment um i
just wanted to remind everybody on
something that perhaps we can all agree
on and that is that newton albert town
centre does need investment
um the do-nothing option for newtonia
but long-term is is one of failure for
the town in our district um we need it
to shift from traditional retail to you
know more of a predominantly leisure
destination but also with revived
markets so i'm hoping that's something
we can at least all agree on
um
and we need to remember too that the
future high street fund projects began
with a community vision made several
years ago that was the right vision in
my opinion and many others
but these projects have had to survive a
pandemic and are now faced with probably
the worst economic situation for decades
if not more and all of that against a
background of a climate emergency
which hasn't been mentioned yet i don't
think
um so as the detail of the projects have
emerged you know people have had
legitimate questions about
design how the projects link together
the effect on each other
my concerns about carbon reduction and
the quality of the build are in there as
well
but still the do nothing option is not a
sensible option what we've got to do
first is try our damnedness to get these
projects right
and that is what we have been trying to
do
and other councils have been suffering
this exact same problem that are dealing
with future high street fund projects or
any other government-funded projects
and what is sad in that context is that
the government seems to steadfastly be
sticking to its line and won't recognize
the issues being experienced by us and
other councils who are trying to deliver
regeneration projects in our towns and
they just won't help us with any extra
money in spite of totally unprecedented
in fresh inflationary pressures
so perhaps we ought to be spending some
of our time pressurizing the government
to contribute more and pushing for
extended delivery deadlines
it's interesting i know that devon
county council possibly have slightly
different language around deadlines on
government grants and
and um seem to imply that they can shift
those a bit so i'd like to see us trying
that um but you know we're being held
hostage here to government funding
criteria with them showing no flex
whatsoever but us suffering all the
angst in our council chambers around the
country
um but it is true you know sort of
against this background what concerns me
is what others have mentioned
that this won't be the last time we're
asked for more money um so the cinema is
not the only project you've got the
market hall um you know it could be that
we're asked to contribute more money
there inflation isn't isn't uh going to
go away anytime soon
so you know at some point in any project
um i'm not an expert in project delivery
but i have had some training in it
there come points where you have to
review where you are
and this is one of those points where
you know the level of nervousness and
risk around this
does need reassessing we need to assess
whether we are on the right track and
whether the risks just are too great to
proceed and i and i would be sadder than
most of us here about um you know us
having to
drop this set of projects all together
um and you know it's been me that said
we ought to be brave and bold like other
towns and and i've reflected on seeing
the success they've had from being brave
and bold but equally there's a thin line
then to um being foolish um we're in
very very difficult situation and um i
think now is the right time to sort of
step back reassess
and that's why i support um the original
amendment i don't see any problem in us
seeking advice on the future of cinema i
mean as um
phil shears has said we i i believe we
have sought advice on the future of
cinemas but if someone else wants to
engage someone else to look at the
future of cinemas that's fine by me as
well um you know we need to be looking
at the entire set of information and
background to the um
giving of more money to this this
project and potentially future um asks
for money as well
thanks
thank you council hook um
councillor malone
yeah just to say something that i don't
think can be said enough but
seemingly
doesn't seem to matter in this uh in
this debate
nobody goes to the cinema anymore
yeah they don't they just don't bloody
go you go to scott cinema on the opening
day of a new release and see how much
space you've got around i'm sorry can i
swim alone there's a point in
just a moment
in one way and that is selling sugary
snacks on the way in that's where they
make it
in just a moment please there is a point
to order from councillor
thank you firstly i go to cinema but
secondly can we focus on the questions
that's in front of us enough please go
off on to uh flights of fantasies thank
you very much excuse me i'm not allowed
to interrupt other people when they're
making their points just by saying i'd
like to make a point in the middle of
that so uh why is counselor bulovan
afforded that luxury please
if i can just finish my point please
view councilman please finish it quickly
they're both going down the plug hole
we've got scots which can't even quarter
fill a house on the first day of a new
release on a bank holiday this is
delusional
you know
delay it discuss it do whatever you like
but this is bonkers you're building a
cathedral in the desert and it's going
to be a monument to how stupid this
council is
so can we just bear that in mind thank
you it will be born in mine council
malone uh councillor pesarik
thank you chairman just a couple of
quick questions if i make this and i'll
hang on to the mic for the second one if
i may
i've heard different figures mentioned
uh by um council mcgregor and also
councillor jeffries as to the cost of
this cinema what's it going to cost less
than six hundred thousand places
i think cancer pedophilia that's
probably for the part two debate when we
get into the details uh can we put that
on hold please
thank you
councillor connect obviously something
move let me go into part two so we can
have the
discussion on ordinary matches
it has been proposed that we move into
part two
where it is recommended that under
section 100a
brackets four of the local government
act of 72 the press and public be
excluded from the meeting during
consideration of the following item on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraphs three financial
matters of part one of schedule 12 a of
the act i propose
that we move now into part two do i have
a second for that thank you councillor
keeling
can we have a vote with show of hands
please those in favor of moving into
part two
[Music]
those against
and any abstentions
thank you it is carried so we will now
move into part two which involves
various bits of tech technical
adjustment and ask the members of the
public please to adjourn themselves from
the from the venue
i just remind members of the public that
we will be going back into part one for
the vote and you will be invited to come
back and join us
okay
if uh councillors and members of the
public and officers thanks for coming
back um
we will be going to the vote shortly on
uh councillor malone's
uh amendment to council o'connor's
amendment
and but before that
i'm going to ask
officer blaney just to summarize from
the officer's point of view
what the implications of the decision
that we're about to vote on might be
real
thank you
thank you members um so
just to summarize where we are the
purpose of the recommendation today is
to secure additional funding that will
enable scott cinemas to sign the lease
with us and to allow the council to
progress the cinema project
without scots being legally committed we
cannot move forward with this part of
the project so the decision today
is to refuse then clearly the project
and if the decision today is to defer
then this presents a significant risk to
the delivery time scale so the necessary
actions required to move the project
forward will have to be paused we can't
commit resource and cost
when there's uncertainty and no
authorization to move forward so
officers will need to delay and pause
work that is currently planned in these
next few weeks and months to move the
project forward to the necessary time
scales
and that then as discussed
earlier will mean that we're unlikely to
meet the task skills required to draw
down the grant funding
within the part 2 report we set out the
safeguards that are in place to protect
the council's position and public money
there's a condition as well that allows
us to review costs and walk away if the
costs are too high
and return to
um the amendment performed by council of
connot in amendment 1 the actions
set out being asked to to refer to
external auditors are already inbuilt
into our processes um we are able to
provide the executive with updates on
costs and progresses uh in line with
amendment two um this has already been
done on a monthly basis with the
executive member so it won't be
an issue to to move that into a more
formal report um but turn into to
uh obviously item number three about
pause and um there is significant risk
to the project
uh by adding any further delays into
this thank you
thank you officer uh
jeffrey
councillor jefferies sorry we had
councillor mcgregor then council
jefferies
thank you chair um thank you neil for
the explanation
i also wanted to bring up a point having
worked with government funding central
government funding before
is it fair is perhaps the portfolio
holder can can confirm this is it fair
to say that if we fail to deliver this
project
uh at all
then that
impacts on our ability to bid for
funding in future because we'll be
scored against our performance on
uh delivering projects that we we
either fail to deliver or have delays on
thank you
thank you council mcgregor councillor
jefferies thank you councillor mcgregor
it was just going to be my exact point
um as a former funding officer i just
wanted to highlight that um
projects that
potentially don't meet the criteria or
at the end
don't complete
you're much more likely to look less
favorably on any projects that come
forward in the future and based on their
deliverability so it's very important
that we think about that or have that in
our minds when we're thinking about how
the government may look at our future
capital projects in terms of how we
deliver on this project
thank you
thank you council jeffries uh
councillor foden
thank you
since the future high street fund was
set up by the government
some years ago several years ago
the economic situation of team bridge
and the whole country has hugely changed
and the government knows this
so since this council applied for future
high street funding some years ago
and
the amendment councillor connects
amendments which i do support
can we use this opportunity to ask the
government to call on the government
whether we can revise the projects
including the proposed cinema in which
the funds are to be spent
we are not the only local authority that
is having problems
um implementing the future high street
funds and their projects
so in order that we can still benefit
newton abbott and team ridge with the 5
million
funding
put forward by the future high street
funding
can we
approach the government
to
review the future high street fund and
the way
that the funding has to be spent
because things have hugely changed thank
you
thank you council folder
managing director
i think i can only reiterate that we've
already approached future high streets
we've asked them there is no certainty
um there may be a little bit of stretch
over a month but there is no certainty
that the
the civil servant um
has said yeah the deadline is a deadline
but then who knows where the with the
fluid government we've got and the fact
that we haven't had ministers or civil
servants there being able to answer
questions they've been engaged in other
other projects we've also lobbied the mp
for this so neil had a meeting a couple
weeks ago with rnp to ask her to take
action um
and we we chased that up as well trying
to ask for exactly that um so far we've
been told that there is no movement
there is no extra money um but to
reiterate what i said earlier the
officers that have worked and we're
trying to put together the change
request to retain the wall um and to do
a renovation of the market and to build
the cinema as it's proposed to you today
with the four screens
um
was looked upon favorably by the civil
servant although he couldn't or she he
or she couldn't commit to it until they
saw the change request and as neil said
the viability of what is their model so
we don't prepare a business model as you
or i would normally consider it there is
a whole host of unfortunate ways in
which the government like you do um
likely to go through the calculations
because obviously public spending is
slightly different to
borrowing the money to your bank and
then perhaps putting either your house
or or your business at risk on that
because the borrowing you have so
there's a very different criteria for
for the way in which they assess the the
return so i think i think hopefully you
should have comfort that one we've
already asked that we will continue to
lobby on that that basis as well um
because there is no sense in us not
doing that um
and but the the the revised proposals if
we exclude the alexandra um means that
the the project looks more affordable
because it reduces the construction
costs of the whole project the totality
of it potentially meaning that we could
cope without having to ask for more
money and the 9.2 million will be as we
initially envisaged but obviously moving
bits of that budget around within the
within the scope of the projects within
the the overall project so minor
elements may have some movement from one
to another but we think we could deliver
a revised market hall proposal the
cinema and the uh high street
improvements as well
but obviously your decision today has a
significant impact on that and and
you know as officers are set out there
is a risk that that you know
we don't know what will happen with the
decision so i i can't
we aren't we aren't able to give you
uh exact advice on this there is a level
of risks that you need to to assess
yourselves and make that brave decision
one way or the other what you want from
it
uh thank you mr shares i have councillor
college and councillor colcroft
councillor connect
thank you chairman uh with regard to
councillor foden uh i'm very happy to
write a letter to
the new prime minister with the managing
director just pointing out the pressure
not for just for team bridge but other
future high street fund councils because
of the exceptional rise in construction
cost inflation i think that may be a
point that could be well made to
government um
in terms of um council malone's
amendment i'm quite happy to accept that
as part of the amendment i've made
and to carry that forward and just in
terms of the points that
officer neil malone made
clearly the council has been progressing
somewhat at risk having not had the
contract signed for
[Music]
the cinema element um and we've we've
done that and carried on quite as we
should uh the amendment before council
that i made at the start of the meeting
is simply for uh some external
reassurance um which will help validate
uh the members decision i don't see that
provides any greater risk uh given that
we have a projected planning date for
the cinema towards the end of the year
and i think that work could be done very
very quickly
and for the council to make a robust and
informed decision thank you chairman
thank you council connect councillor
colcroft
yeah
time seems to be of the essence here and
we're dependent on scots uh forming a
legal degree agreement with the council
to to take over this cinema project
and now
how long have they have they got to come
back with telling us or forming this
legal agreement i mean does it just go
on and on because time is of the essence
so is there a deadline
waiting for scots to come back one way
or another or whether they're going to
agree to take over this project
can i ask officer phillips to respond to
that question please
thank you very much i'm mindful of the
public nature of this we have all terms
agreed and it's both parties intention
to proceed to exchange a contract by the
end of this month
should we have approval here today
uh thank you officer phillips
right i think that brings us to the
point now where we have to uh consider
to vote on
uh councillor malone's amendment to ask
the head of democracy
to speak to the amendment just
can you just check i was just going to i
was going to ask the head of democratic
services to read it out and then ask you
for any comment
but before that chair can you
can you address with council malone and
councillor connor
what on number three it says adjourned
to a date to be confirmed that with
respect doesn't really mean
anything
when and who confirms the council of
connect and council malone the
monitoring officer asking in
part three of yours
now adjourns to a date to be confirmed
what does that mean
chairman with the most expediency one
assumes that if council support the
amendment uh they commissioned the work
from the external external auditors as
soon as that report has been uh
presented
the council
could reassemble of course i can't give
that date because i don't know how
quickly that would be possible to do but
i imagine that our officers and our
external auditors will work with great
speed to ensure that the decision that
the information and report is available
to councils quickly and so as is normal
my anticipation is that the rev new date
uh for a reconvened council meeting
would be set uh by you in consultation
with relevant officers chairman
thank you
if if the leader
said that he's sorry
the leader said that he's happy to
incorporate my
um my amendment into
the other three he's got
if that's the case can we not just vote
on that as a set
without having to
devote debate whether mine is in there
or not
yes that's what we've had that's what we
proposed to do but i was going to ask
the head of democratic services to read
out your amendment because councillors
including myself may have forgotten
precisely what it was we've seen
cancer conits on paper and then we will
vote out on it as a job lot thank you
for clearing that up
sarah could you read out the uh
councillor
yes
councilman please do um comment if i
haven't got the word incorrect
the council resolves to engage
consultants specialized in cinemas and
the night time economy in order to
establish how viable a new full screen
cinema is
do you have any further comment counsel
them alone
as a whole
yes
um that was seconded by councillor pat's
that remember wasn't it and councillor
connick you're
yeah um and your second year at sepsis
which was counselor
keeling thank you
so we are voting on what is effectively
now one amendment
um
all those in favor
what they're voting for
yeah okay thank you
councillor austin
councillor bradford
councillor bullavent
councillor kolploff
councillor david cox
councillor hugh cox
councillor evans
councillor foden
councillor gribble
councillor hayes
councillor hawking or
councillor gordon hook
councillor jackie hooke
councillor jeffrey
councillor jefferies
councillor kealing
councillor kurzweil
councillor mcgregor
councillor morgan
councillor malone
councillor nutley
councillor parker
councillor patch
swain councillor taylor
councillor thorne
cancer clarence abstain
and yourself chair
four
kid
that's carrie chair
uh thank you very much so that means
that the recommendation put forward by
um
by the
executive member for economy and jobs to
move is is withdrawn in the light of the
passing of the amendment i think that
brings us to the end of this morning's
business and i declare the meeting
adjourned
you